physics one could say is an assault of a
crisis in some sense because of a
current gap between the sophisticated
theories which came from applying
sophisticated mathematics and the actual
universe
so we have theories first which describe
10-dimensional worlds 10 dimensional
space-time coming from string theory and
things like that
but we don't know yet how to
apply it to understanding our universe
a lot of progress has been made but it's
kind of a a kind of impasse right now
and at the same time the
our most realistic theories most
advanced theories of the
four-dimensional universe are in
contradiction with each other
the standard model describing the
three four known forces of nature the
electromagnetic strong and weak
it was great accuracy and Einstein's
relativity which describes the fourth
called gravity
everybody above a certain age knows that
one yeah
so these two theories are in
contradiction at the moment and string
theory was one of the the promise of
string theory was that it would unify
those two and so far it has not has not
happened so we are kind of at a very
interesting place right now and uh I
think that new ideas perhaps I needed
and I I wouldn't be surprised if Wheaton
is one of those people who come up with
those ideas well he has been one of the
one of the people that added a lot of
ideas under the flag of string theory
uh what do you think about this Theory
what do you think is beautiful about it
string theory
well first of all kind of
um you remember we talked about
pythagoreans and how for pythagoreans
the whole world was the symphony where
you have this different vibrations of
all the humans every human is a
vibration every every animal you know
every being every tree and every
Celestial body and so on
so strings that is kind of like that
because in string theory there is this
fundamental object which is a vibrating
string
and all particles are in a sense
supposed to be different modulations of
vibrations of that string so that by
itself is already interesting that you
kind of
describe this diversity of various
particles and interactions between them
using one guiding principle in some
sense
but also just the mathematical things
that come out of it the uh the kind of
um it looks impossible to satisfy
various constraints and then that is
sort of like a unique way to do it so
that's sort of the
every time that happens when you know
you have some system over like over
determined system let's suppose
you have to do like five interviews in
one day yeah and you wake up in the
morning and you're like that's
impossible because then so many things
have to align for instance let's suppose
you have to go from one place to another
so then you have a commute and then who
knows maybe there is a traffic jam and
stuff like that and now suppose that it
all works seamlessly and there were like
a bunch of places where it could have
gone hopelessly wrong and it didn't and
then in the evening you're like wow it
worked that's beautiful right that's
kind of like a great luck you know we
would say but
in science this happens sometimes that
you have this Theory which not supposed
to work because there's so many
seemingly contradictory demands on it
and yet there is a sweet spot where they
balance each other so string theory is
kind of like this
the unfortunate aspect of it is that it
balances itself in 10 dimensions and not
in four
so maybe there is another Universe
somewhere
where but see as a mathematician
for me all spaces are created equal yeah
10 dimensional four-dimensional so
mathematicians love String Theory
because it has given us so much so much
food for thought
but do you think
it's a correct
or a incorrect theory for understanding
this reality
so it might be a theory that explains
sometimes the Metro reality in some
other universe but is it potentially
what do you think are the odds again
Financial advice if you were to bet
what do you think are the odds that um
it gets us closer to understanding this
reality
well in the form that it is now that
seems unlikely but it could well be that
based on these ideas with some
modifications with some essential new
elements
uh it could it could work out so I would
say right now it doesn't look so good
like from the point of view that we of
what we from what we know
but maybe somebody will come in into
juice like square root of negative one I
mean they already introduced but I mean
kind of like as a metaphor yeah maybe
somebody will come and say what if we do
this it looks crazy you know speaking of
news boor
he had this famous quote that he said to
somebody
uh there is no doubt that your theory is
crazy the question is whether it's crazy
enough to describe reality so that's
where we are kind of you know